sophie yerlès bonjour bonjour vous êtes
chargé de mission à l'osmothèque de
versailles
d'abord comment on pourrait définir
l'osmothèque c'est à la fois un
conservatoire un musée mais c'est plus
que ça alors c'est un conservatoire
international de parfum donc on conserve
ici
trois mille parfums dont 4,5 qui ont
déjà disparu des marchés commerciaux
donc notre but est de mettre en valeur
le patrimoine de la parfumeuse et
l'histoire voit la fin exactement
mais c'est pas uniquement conservatoire
dans le sens où notre but c'est aussi de
transmettre le savoir des parfumeurs au
grand public et aux professionnels
donc on a une équipe de parfumeurs
bénévoles qui qui donne des conférences
sur l'histoire de la parfumerie ou sur
des thèmes ou beaucoup plus pointu à
chacun de venir s'intéresser aux sujets
qui m'intéressent et à chaque fois qu'il
ya un fabricant de parfums qui sort un
nouveau parfum ce qui vous il vous la
mène il vous le donne il faut il vous
donne la formule alors ça dépend des
marques et ça dépend de la relation
qu'on a avec ses marines et elle
incertaine qui nous connaissent déjà
très bien et qui comprennent tout à fait
l'intérêt de cette institution
à ce moment là ils envoient leurs
parfums sans aucun problème celles qui
ne connaissent pas encore c'est un peu
plus difficile parce qu'il faut se faire
connaître il faut leur leur exposé
l'intérêt de notre institution
oui vous voir que
leur montrer que c'est pas pour
reproduire pas fin à leur piquer la
formule que vous les voulez alors
pourquoi cette à versailles s'avérer
historique on est hébergé par l'isie cac
est une école de parfumerie cosmétique à
rome
donc c'était très cohérent pour nous de
se situer dans cette école et donc et en
plus ils font partie de deux des
fondateurs un des financeurs de
l'osmothèque qui est une association à
but non lucratif d'accord qui a été
fondée au col de 90 analyse pas un
parfumeur
oui j'en quart des eaux qui était
parfumeur chez jean patou et qui a eu
cette idée géniale de recréer des
parfums anciens et 2 de là est née
l'idée de ce conservatoire et
aujourd'hui on a grandi on se retrouve
avec une belle collection de trois mille
parfums
aujourd'hui c'est notre part fumeuses ou
parfaitement je sais pas comment
trimatis jan mikolaj qui préside qui
président de la ce n'était qu'un oui
c'est ça depuis six ans déjà six ans
alors là on se trouve beau jeu c'est pas
très grand mais en fait non je vous ai
cassé en gros 2 2 deux pièces on verra
l'autre après là on se trouve à 7 quand
on arrive on est là alors il ya
évidemment des départs fin
qu'on voit derrière nous qui sont des
parfums qui n'existe plus pour la
plupart alors ce qui se trouve exposé
ici ça dépend par exemple il ya ici le
coffret des parfums de rosine way
qui sont les parfums de paul poiret
turier du début du 20e siècle
donc ça évidemment c'est une marque qui
a disparu et ce coffret là c'est une
pièce historique est importante
après on expose aussi des parfums
d'aujourd'hui pour que les gens s'y
reconnaissent quand où il retrouve les
leurs voilà exactement
donc ça c'est ça c'est la première pièce
il ya derrière nous ça s'appelle un
orgueil ça oui c'est ça largo du
parfumeur qui est l orgue de gens car
léo le fondateur de l'osmothèque c'est
le sien promo à celui avec lequel
travailler avec le cas alors il ya
coyette toutes les senteurs tout au tout
les toutes les audaces aux senteurs qui
permet de proposer un parfum voilà ce
soit ma chère qui l'utilisé pour créer
ces c'est propre parfum comment comment
ça se passe dire qu'on compte ou créé un
parfum
évidemment on n'a pas le droit de créer
un parfum qui existe déjà et comment on
sait d'ailleurs si on fait quelque chose
de tout à fait originale ou quoi là
c'est la créativité du parfumeur il faut
savoir que toute création découle d'un
parfum qui a déjà existé c'est très rare
qu'on parte de pages blanches
donc voilà n'est pas les parfumeurs en
général on on leur parfum fétiche et
ceux qui les inspirent et à partir de là
où ils viennent de retravailler avec les
matières qui qu'ils aiment et on parle
ce monde d'obsession même pour certaines
matières chez les parfumeurs et aux
comptes on s'y connaît un petit peu et
évidemment on voit tout de suite la
différence entre c'est pas votre
guerlain dior enfin je parle des grands
fumeurs non oui il ya des signatures
olfactives pour guerlain on appelle ça
la guerre l'inad sur un fond de vanille
donc c'est très marqué
pour cette marque là en particulier
c'est très marquée et dans cette école
alors vous n'êtes pas responsables des
écoles mais c'est là qu'on forme des
nids ou pas oui c'est l'école la plus
prestigieuse qu'il existe pour le moment
donc les promotions sont de 20 élèves
par an et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes et les élèves sont enfin il
convient de 8 euros sur vingt personnes
c'est tout petit tout aussi c'est assez
peu et malgré ça on sait très bien que
sur le marché du travail
en tout cas de la place parce que c'est
un métier où qu'ils naviguent et oui pas
des débouchés ya venant pas énormément
de parfumeurs je sais pas si vous en
connaissez autour de vous c'est quand
même un métier
et qu'est ce qu'il faut pour être un bon
né il ya parce que c'est pas juste de
l'instinct je vous ai faut plutôt que
d'être la chimie alors pour intégrer les
deux cas on leur demande
on demande aux étudiants d'avoir un bac
+3 en chimie des cibistes 1 voilà
d'autres personnes vous diront qu'on n'y
a pas vraiment besoin de deux chimistes
et de la création c'est une forme d'art
donc ça dépend des efforts et pour cause
on voit là et ça dépend des écoles il ya
une pièce qui est de passionnantes ici
c'est ce que vous appelez je prends la
cave
oui on l'appelle la caste et la salle où
on conserve tous ses parfums et matières
premières qui me permette d'aller
refaire donc de la voir
oui bien sûr ce fearless à leur date
nous sommes dans la cave ou de
l'osmothèque donc produire presque les
cadres parce que ce sont deux cas oui ce
sont des canadiens alors c'est là que
sont conservés et des parfums existants
et des parfums qui n'existe plus alors
là vous m'avez pas donné je vous le
rendrai c'est absolument incroyable ça
c'est un parfum qui datent du premier
siècle oui enfin c'est une
reconstitution mort de quelqu'un mais on
avait des textes oui qui permettait de
reconstituer ses parfums voilà les
textes de pline l'ancien en l'occurrence
qui a laissé assez de détails pour qu'on
puisse retrouver les matières premières
qui constituait ce parfum qui est
utilisé à cette époque je pense qu'on
peut pas le sentir c'est selon moi on va
le sentir
ah bon oui s'ouvre alors c'est une des
grandes curiosités de l'osmothèque
génial 1er siècle
incroyable voyez là une couleur sang
fort ah oui oui des moulins oui spécial
parce qu'il a été enfin son le solvant
c'est le zoo oui ça sent très parce que
l'alcool n'existait pas encore assez ça
avec quoi vous aviez des plantes
évidemment oui surtout des plantes
aromatiques comme le romarin
du miel aussi connaissait le parfum en
fond existe depuis tout enfin oui
pratiquement avec la naissance de la
civilisation et c'était quoi c'était oui
c'était parfois magiques un peu aussi
c'était parce qu'en crèche où il avait
un côté d'un mystique bain mais les
populations communiquer avec les dieux à
travers les parfums ou les fumées
parfumée c'est au nom je le met dans la
poche selon laurent tout à l'heure ou
chromé alors donc dans ces clubs là il
ya des parfums des parfois que qui ont
disparu mais nous devons garder la
mémoire de conserver le même alors plus
récents que depuis que j'attende plus
anciens mais mais enfin qui quand même
certaines personnes me dit souvent mais
exact mais qui n'existe plus que tu as
voulu fabriquer parce que quand les
maisons de disques plus pointus mais
voilà oui ça peut être une des raisons
je vais vous montrer par exemple de
lambres antique de coty donc otis et
es11 du seco des années quoi 50 un
parent avancées au début du siècle
oui donc là on est en 1905
ah oui des cloques c'est un des premiers
parfums qui là qu'il a créée soutien
parce que oui c'est bien bouché un oui
mais aussi du et ça c'est la grande
époque du père pendant le we du siècle
afin d'user vienne début 20e
oui c'est la naissance de
de la personne moderne voilà avec les
des coûts les grandes découvertes
chimiques qui ont permis d'étoffer leur
goût du parfumeur et tu es sens fort et
donc aux ti est très connu pour ses
créations mais aussi sa façon de 2
commercial des halles parfum ah oui
c'était un parmi un des premiers moderne
voilà là dessus alors tant que je vous
en laisse à merci beaucoup je suis là
aussi non à oui ça n'a rien à voir
tu es plus tu crées plus je crois enfin
je ne sais pas oui cette poudre et
audrey oui poudre est absolument des
greens poudre de femmes un oui c'est
très exactement et donc et comment on
reconstitue là on a les formules pour
les parfums qui datent de la fin d'une
niche du but 20e
on a la chance d'avoir les formules de
ses partants qui sont de très grands
parfums c'est pas le cas de tous les
parfums ou non quand on n'a pas la
formule est que la marque n'existe plus
on considère que son départ fin perdu à
jamais ouais et donc il ya aussi des
parfums qui existe toujours il à dos
dont les pas falloir vous donne la
formule alors ils nous aident pas
forcément la formule surtout si la
marque existe encore il nous envoie
simplement leur parfum ils vous envoient
les parfums d'accord donc ça on peut
trouver aussi vrai il ya beaucoup vous
avez combien de parfums ici 3000 au
total robin autochtone ah oui c'est
quand même incroyable
donc je peux vous présentez un parfum
qui existe encore aujourd'hui je joue
l'ouvrir oui si tu sais plus et 9 pouces
ou sas aide et parfois qui existe
aujourd'hui
voilà go bon alors
les particuliers qui viendrait à
versailles ou bien ils n'ont pas la
chance comme nous de pénétrer dans ce
texte sauf s'il ya des conférences ça
exactement alors oui oui on organise des
conférences pour partager cette
formidable collection avec wii avec le
public
alors la cave par contre cette salle est
toujours fermé au public
d'accord c'est trop précieux par contre
on les reçoit et on leur raconte
l'histoire de la parfumerie ou
une conférence sur un thème précis et
donc on les fait toujours sentir
on leur fait sentir une vingtaine ou
trentaine de parfums par conférence la
cave elle est ouverte aux chercheurs aux
étudiants enfin oui en fait oui en fait
des séances de la faction notamment pour
les étudiants de logica qui veulent pas
aborder un sujet précis donc par exemple
on peut leur faire sentir tous les
parfums coty c'est hyper d'accord oui
c'est vrai c'est le seul endroit où on
va les trouver donc c'est intéressant de
comprendre la signature olfactive et ben
merci beaucoup sauf il reste pour cette
visite de ce lieu assez extraordinaire
un fait exceptionnel qui se trouvent dos
à versailles il et qui s'appelle
l'osmothèque merci beaucoup avec plaisir